glass started out life as a hundred and
fifty page script which is M night
Shyamalan longest screenplay to date and
he did film that whole script which gave
him a first cut of three hours and 20
minutes over an hour of footage from
that early cut was deleted as the movie
was edited down to around two hours and
ten minutes
given that Shyamalan financed much of
the twenty million budget of glass
himself it's understandable that he
wishes he'd been a bit harsher during
the writing process and purred down the
script before shooting began still that
means we've got some interesting deleted
scenes to talk about yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers I'm John and in this video I'm
going to reveal and explain seven
intriguing scenes that were deleted from
class including an alternate ending
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the
film yet one of the most striking
deleted scenes from glass takes place in
the corridors of the psychiatric
hospital in the cutscene we see several
of the hospital's other patients
approaching the beast and as they do so
he seems to be laying hands on them as
if they're having an almost religious
experience the Beast believes that only
those who suffered are pure so it's
natural that he would see the other
patients at a psychiatric hospital as
his followers Shyamalan has said he
chose a mustard color for the beasts
clothing because it's associated with
religious ceremonies and he regards the
beast as an evangelist a preacher who
wants to help save the broken and
remember that a number of Kevin's
personalities including Patricia and
Dennis talked about the Beast in
religious terms
for example referencing his prey as
sacred food doctor staple Eva refers to
Patricia as a kind of high priestess and
when doubt about the beast finally
creeps in Patricia says that her horde
is losing faith it would seem logical
therefore if the full deleted scene also
showed us the beast preaching and
converting the patients to his cause in
the final film we see David Dunn aka the
overseer demonstrate his superpowers
just once before the movie moves on to
him tracking down and battling the Beast
that scene in the movie takes place in
the home of two men who randomly
attacked a passerby on the street and
uploaded a video of the attack to the
Internet however another scene of
David's crime-fighting exploits in the
city was deleted from the movie in this
trailer footage that didn't make it into
the final film you can see the overseer
slamming someone up against what looks
like it could be a subway wall if you
look carefully at the
you can also see someone lying on the
floor with the contents of their handbag
or purse filled out on the ground beside
them all of which points to the person
on the floor having been assaulted or
mugged by the guy being thrown against
the wall by the overseer this scene
looks like it's part of a longer
introduction to Dunn's vigilante
activities and so I expect it was curt
to get to the main action of done versus
the beast more quickly and also trimmed
down the movie's runtime Shyamalan made
good using glass of several deleted
scenes from unbreakable including one
with young Elijah a surfer and another
with Joseph telling David that he knows
his secret identity but those weren't
the only deleted scenes from the nearly
20 year old film that the director was
going to include in the final part of
his trilogy originally a deleted and
breakable scene where David speaks to a
priest was also going to feature in
glass in the scene which takes place in
a church David tells a priest that he
feels the fact that he was the sole
survivor of the train wreck means
something important
however the priest who also lost family
in the crash tells David in no uncertain
terms that his survival is no hand of
God miracle moment you were chosen
thanks
Shyamalan had said he decided to cut
this powerful scene from glass at the
last moment and I think that the scene
probably appeared just after the group
therapy session when we see David Dunn
sitting alone in his room looking
despondent it would have fit perfectly
there as David is clearly shaken by dr.
staples words about how all his suppose
it superpowers are just a matter of
intuition and tricks so it makes sense
that he might think back in that moment
to someone else from his past the priest
who likewise doubted that he was special
it was like actor James McAvoy also had
an extended scene with the cheerleaders
at the beginning of the movie the final
film starts with Dennis and Patricia off
screen discussing people's lack of
belief in the Beast then we see Patricia
introduce herself to the four abducted
girls that look like a PB and J sandwich
however according to Shyamalan in the
original script the opening sequence
with Patricia was much longer the
director thought he needed to explain
how Kevin had multiple personalities and
so the cheerleaders were going to go
through a similar set of scenes as Casey
and the two girls did when they were
first abducted and split in the end
though Shyamalan realized he was just
repeating things people had already seen
in that film and that he didn't need the
extra scenes in class to properly
reintroduce the audience to Kevin Wendel
creminis various identities kevin has a
total of 24 personalities including the
beast in split we saw eight of those
identities on display either in person
or via the video recordings on Kevin's
computer but while glass showed us many
more personalities James McAvoy's
confirmed us although he filmed 23 of
Kevin's identities only 20 of them made
the final cut of the film I've compared
the list of characters that McAvoy is
credited for in glass against the full
list of Kevin's identities revealed on
his computer in split and it looks like
the missing characters in glass of
Bernice Raquel and Ansel as well as all
well who he did see a clip of in split
Shyamalan has said that because he was
originally going to include 23 out of
Kevin's 24 identities and glass at one
point he was going to do a contest to
tell them which character is not in the
movie anyway I'm hoping that on the
blu-ray we get to see an extended scene
of dr. staple meeting Kevin's multiple
identities which shows us the remaining
personality is not seen in either of the
movies there's also an interesting
little moment with David in the group
therapy session that ended up being
scrapped so you're not gonna shake my
hand and let me walk out of here he's
talking here - dr. staple and have this
clip in in the final film it would have
been a chilling bit of foreshadowing of
how towards the end of the movie dr.
staple holds David's hand and watches on
while he's drowned in a puddle by one of
the secret societies henchmen I wonder
if the ultimate decision to scrap this
brief clip was partly because Shyamalan
felt it tipped its hat a little too
early to the fact that David Dunn would
find out something sinister about dr.
stapling her hand the finale of Glass
has proved divisive among fans but
samuel l.jackson has revealed that
initially the movie had a different
ending in an interview with Digital Spy
he explained that the original ending
was changed because of the way society
is and what's going on in the world and
what it would have looked like
Jackson's comments a rather vague but
one possibility is that originally the
black clover secret societies of
pressing super-powered individuals was
men
to be a covert agency of the government
rather than a group whose affiliations
are never clearly stated when dr.
staples henchmen arrived there dressed
and labeled like regular law-enforcement
officials or SWAT teams given that glass
is set in the present if the twist was
going to be that it was the government
that was secretly repressing and
assassinating supers then it might have
felt the movie was trying to make a
deliberate political point and then the
possibility is that the final twist was
changed as it ended the movie on an even
darker note which was also the reason
that Shyamalan changed the original
ending of his previous movie split of
course the three main characters are
killed off in glass but what if after
Elijah's mother Joseph and Casey
released the footage to the world it
ended up being dismissed as fake news by
the government or the media during the
final scene we hear mr. glass say
whoever these people are who don't want
us to know the truth
today they lose but I wonder if an
earlier draft saw the government
discrediting the footage and covering up
the whole affair I don't know if
Shyamalan had anything like that in mind
but it would have been a pretty
depressing ending and again given the
movie a more overtly political ending
apparently also as a qa4 glass Shyamalan
talked about how the distributor's
Disney and Universal offered him a
larger budget to make a more climactic
ending it's possible that their idea was
to actually have that big showdown at
the Asarco Tower Shyamalan turned down
the offer however as he says he's not as
comfortable making films with huge
budgets and feels he works better with
smaller ones so he kept this film down
to 20 million overall and it's CGI
budget was only $800,000 a tiny amount
for a superhero movie either way if you
want to know more about the actual
ending in the movie and who the black
clover secret society really represents
then tap here to watch my ending
explained video or check the link in the
video description below now if you could
have had any ending to glass what would
you have liked and do you wish any of
these other deleted scenes have been in
the movie let me know in the comments
below if you enjoyed this and it's your
first time here then i've got loads more
deleted scenes breakdowns plus every
week i upload new videos so why not
subscribe and hit the bell so you don't
miss out tapleft for everything you
missed in the ending - glass or tap
right for another video you're sure to
like thanks for watching and see you
next time UV gay movie